what do you got for me bud
rich is going on you hear me what's good
all right so um
i've been a single dad for like
[ __ ] to what two years i have a
four-year-old so i've been a single dad
for like four years four years and did
you share the story with eric
yeah
did did yours start the same way too or
was it planned
it started the same way it started the
same was there okay eric i i still see
you in the background here so i want you
to pay attention here okay go ahead man
yeah start the same way like just super
beta and all that but
over the time i got turned into an alpha
so now
it's hard for me to like
like how do i teach her how to be
feminine because i don't have
four she's oh she's too small man but um
you know what the awesome thing between
like four and seven eight nine or so
is
she she's gonna do everything you say
she's gonna follow your lead she's gonna
watch your behavior
he's gonna ask questions whatever you
say is like gospel
okay it's only when they're like 9 10 11
that they start asking questions like
well why and i don't think so and i you
know this sort of thing you've got
everything in your power right now
especially if you're like red pill right
like you've unplugged you've seen the
code in the matrix you see how
everything works
explain things to her
right like like at any opportunity like
you know for example so um i've told the
story before um i had to go to the tax
office to drop off some property tax
checks
yeah you know kiddos with me i got my
envelope with the posted at checks and
because it's a government office you
know typical government workers there's
a lot of you know uh left leaning purple
hair short
you know
nasty you know sleeve you know sleeve
tatted
300 pound five you know five foot two
sort of you know clerks there
yeah
so you know we walk out drop off the
checks i'm like uh so what'd you think
of her uh purple hair she's like i don't
know it seems nice i go do you think men
like purple hair you know like do you
think the kind of guys that she wants to
get with like that kind of look i don't
know purple's a nice color
well here's what men like and i
explained to her right like this is what
men are attracted to and i explain how
men are success objects and women are
beauty objects to men sort of thing and
how that dynamic works it's like you
know you have those dialogues right
and you think that um you think that
women can
you thinking that me getting like
an ltr would be a good example not
necessarily not necessarily because
generally speaking most women suck
at dealing with your kid
like it's true like there's a reason why
they call them like step monsters
most women are awful with children that
aren't theirs in fact they for the most
part
tend to kind of despise them like one of
the things you'll notice on dating apps
is a lot of women will say i don't want
to deal with any any man you know with
kids
but like ninety percent of them that are
saying that already have two or three
kids in tow from two or three different
men and they're looking for something
to raise that guy's kids and they don't
want to deal with yours right i don't
know if you read my book
yeah i did
so you came across a section about
single moms and right
yeah so
for those of you that haven't come
across material what you need to
understand is
when you're with a single mom
her kids will be your responsibility you
will have to parent them with no
authority whatsoever
she's also going to have the expectation
that she can parent your kids but with
authority but with no responsibility so
the table kind of flips a little bit you
know when it comes to dads so
are there some women out there that
would be good for your daughter
potentially but you're gonna have to be
very very good at vetting them
okay okay it's just it's just unlikely
because of female nature right the women
are solipsistic they can't see past
their own nose very well they would
prefer to raise their own kids and erase
some other chicks kids in fact i think
women
from what i've experienced and from the
conversations that i've had are probably
way worse than men they don't want much
to do with a guy with kids in tow
yeah i've seen
plenty of girls tell me on dating apps
they don't want to date a guy with kids
and i still i mean that says nothing to
me but yeah
well it means nothing to you because
you're like chad enough to get past that
barrier right like you know yeah get
past that [ __ ] test right because you
got the look you got the style you got
all this sort of thing going for you but
you're still going to have a hard time
finding a woman that's that's that's
going to complement your life and also
complicate your daughter's life right
yeah yeah yeah right so i mean like you
can really just do what you can with the
time that you have like you share
custody issue with you full time like
how does it work she's with me full time
like the whole whole thing where's the
mom in the picture
uh you probably can answer that better
than i can
i don't know
i had custody whenever when she was like
one years old her mom's like [ __ ]
cracked out and [ __ ] so
okay so she's a real train wreck then
all right so i mean like you want to
make sure that okay so so what you're
saying basically is how do i make sure
that she doesn't turn into her mom yeah
without me because i'm like super
masculine sometimes i feel like she
needs like
someone feminine to like really do you
have a sister
no it's all brothers
and is your mom still around
yeah she's with my mom a lot but my
mom's [ __ ]
you know
i mean my mom is
super old beliefs and you can do
whatever you want and
yeah
it could be the president all that
okay well i mean like the problem with
um
putting putting her in the hands of
other women is that you want her in the
hand because i mean you're asking
specifically like how do i you know
teach her to be feminine right like how
do i teach her to be something yeah into
the world and to men you know sort of
thing is
anything that's going to influence her
to like subscribe to
like most of the female population right
now is drunk on like the
like the toxic feminist rhetoric yeah
yeah you take her to girl guides
it's going to be run by that sort of
category you know you take her to
some other you know girl sort of event
sort of thing
in fact you're going to be hard-pressed
to find feminine women that are willing
to impart you know traditional you know
like feminine sort of cues that you want
her to learn so if your mom didn't do it
you're gonna have to find it somewhere
else you don't have a sister so that's
odd
date i mean you know maybe you're gonna
come across a chick that's got a
four-year-old daughter as well i mean
this is the only circumstance where i
said in my book you know because people
challenge me all the time well what
circumstance would you recommend guys
date a woman with kids okay well here's
one for you
she's got a four-year-old daughter as
well she's in your frame she compliments
your life she doesn't bring red flags
you know your kids get along that might
be an environment where that might be
advantageous i mean if you're serious
about you know teaching her those those
life skills
yeah that might be something that could
work so i mean like you could look out
for that as well too
okay
i've never had my kid around any girl i
dated i don't know i just was
i don't know
and and don't right like don't don't say
hey you know do you want to meet my
little girl like let them bring it up
say you know
dig your vibe you know i don't want to
share you with anybody else where do we
stand like you have all those talks sort
of thing and then at some point you know
she's going to be like you know i really
want to meet your daughter like i've
seen a lot of pictures and i've heard a
lot about her and blah blah blah like
she's got a genuine interest in it it's
not just
bs like you got to have to like you know
you've got a few of those you got your
work cut out for you man
yeah
you know you really do have your work
cut out for you so eric i know you're in
that here
hang on a second eric
elijah
eric eric is elijah four years ago
yeah dude he got it you got all right
you got to pull the [ __ ] out of that bro
okay
anyway i'm going to pull you out eric
you get my point though right
yeah for sure all right so i mean like
you got your work cut out for you so you
know you just do the best that you can
yeah all right appreciate it see ya
by the way um some other thing yeah and
you know ryan's got it here in the chat
he said put her in uh gymnastics i
wouldn't say combat sports for for girls
uh gymnastics figure skating
something that's like conventionally
feminine right you know you can do stuff
like that for
you